how's it going bros my name is Lampert
are either impaired it back that's how
you're doing I was raped in the last
episode by these three gentlemen over
here
they're very handsome position I must
say and this is Sher you even scam Shia
pity I'm sure sorry
those aren't mine really friends they
forced me to do it I swear to God do
something bad to them hey we call you
stop I told you to stop in the last
episode whether they came coming natural
she said this flat all right ah [ __ ]
time putting naked guy
can't even breathe let me get a little
stupid bookshelf alright here's a key
I'm afraid of picking things up here I
know karate I know karate okay ah ah all
right I got a light no no no no it's
cool stick this way back stupid
teleporting why don't you even come from
where is your home time who is your
leader as out now oh wait I got a key I
have many keys I am the keymaster
it's not funny anymore man
books oh okay Ted I'm gonna get the
apples are four key okay
key who the [ __ ] is kitty that's a big
apple and I'm not talking about yeah Wow
I hate you stop making love in front of
me
Wow Oh My Jesus penis why is it so dark
and you my logic all right mr. Apple I
don't even know where they come from
these days all right
let's go here all right Apple come with
me ah I knew it I could hear that
clipping it's obvious [ __ ]
teleporting Nicky eyes everywhere this
is a mess this is war oh my god
really it's like can't they put more
jump scares in the game what's with the
[ __ ] Apple I need a kitty cat no I
don't I can do it it might happen it's
my dog [ __ ] yeah I can show it later
oh I don't like this background noises
boxes
red light look at that as a naked man
take the box
not for me barrels you think you're
tough huh
you think you're a tough battle no
you're not I'm your boss
look at that he's peeing in there is
peeing in there ah I know what it's
carpet rituals special people have some
useful things in his body like what a
penis makes no sense
all right let's check this one out then
sup brah like it's box box cool
that's terrific all look is heavy is it
heavy or you squish I don't care alright
let's go here it's a lot oh wait I like
the knife it's in its heart
alright excuse me boxes whoa scare me
why did it just disappear all lemon will
it bounce all right let's go here let's
take it easy
I suspect teleporting naked guys you see
M is right there Justin look more
teleporting Nate you guys
who is your leader bring me [ __ ] don't
make love in front of me cheese guys I
get that you're gay and all but not in
front of me oh no no no I will not be
raped by you
no I won't no no I won't no no no tell
me I should count how many [ __ ] a
teleporting ap Isis is this is a
nightmare
usually one teleporting is wrong it's
bad enough Alice Alice Billy this is
Christ ha ha
it's what it's why it's a battle fit
Jesus Christ tapers on against you tell
about the naked guy said against you
Jesus Christ nothing is as it seems
pretty you need to be careful you need
to be damn careful pity don't cross the
pond no I don't know what it is Stefano
let's just break this hammer it's hammer
time [ __ ] Oh know how it work all
right let me just think sweet jesus
sweet baby right up but did they do the
Espada are you all right yes of course I
am see father what do you expect that's
the potato can do this to me all right
why should we gas the father
I thought we would find a key here no II
don't know things
hey there's key oh now that attempt to
rape me they never stop do they writes
the final yes of course it's your sexy
back video thank you I'm glad he knows
I'm just kidding of course I am a
straight man feeding don't be ridiculous
are you sure yes of course Jesus Christ
I'm fine all right take it easy pity I
suspected I sense naked toy telepathic
Nikki gasps look that yes
don't faster ah but seriously don't hit
me and everything all right I am sorry I
can't live like this
I'm kidnapping and killing people for
nothing I'm addicted to it and the only
way to end this is to kill myself
I am sorry Daniel take this key and
enjoy your freedom and I spoke about the
secret of this house and house of creep
to the sacred is the thing which is
flying around unreal a special potion
it's making that you loot oh no it's all
done it'll loosen it but why can I see
them makes no sense I'm a statue I can't
bring back [ __ ] Wow
does that mean you have gay fantasies of
people hyping you this makes no sense
what is off
everything is twisted hello mayonnaise
hey I waited by you Wow what I'm shy but
where are we in a dramatic mood here
oh I'm shy I'll just share table mode
activate all right let's check this out
for the atom festive
Oh he killed himself but why did he have
to be naked while doing it I guess I'll
never understand alright let's check the
lies room and let's finish this
telepathic naked my nightmare oh my
sweet baby Jesus ah free them at last
with mr. father we should have many
babies together Stephane what are you
talking about you and your gay loves out
Jesus Christ baby sometimes you make me
[ __ ] wander all right don't look back
it looks stupid just walk forward all
right
look how are you supposed to go up there
you do shuffle I don't like this pity is
something supposed to happen
No
is it over either is it all that I've
okay let's just pretend that I mean of
course itself we should have many babies
together pity what Iowa I'm just kidding
this guy's all right hope you guys
enjoyed I am stefano when i fly up in
the air that we will end this video over
the office and someone just logged in
yes - you always forget to logout stupid
answer all right order the sky sky I am
separa
[Music]
[Music]
you
you